so the Oppenheimer movie is finally out
and given that here's a snippet of
conversation I had recently with a real
life modern day nuclear war expert about
the lessons we can learn from
oppenheimer's story and specifically how
these lessons apply to these new
technologies that we're building things
like artificial intelligence and
synthetic biology which just like
splitting the atom could be used for
incredible good but also unimaginable
evil here's what he had to say what
lessons can we draw from the nuclear
situation that we could apply to these
new dilemmas I think it's challenging
because Ai and biotechnology are these
really powerful multiple use
Technologies they're kind of general
purpose in many ways whereas nuclear
weapons were born out of a military
program they were controlled by States
from the start
AI was born from the private sector so
it's a national regulatory problem it's
an international regulatory problem and
the landscape is moving so quickly that
there are very few people right now who
are on the frontier
and understand what's possible and what
would you actually limit Monitor and
regulate if you wanted to do that there
are also real benefits to moving forward
quickly and deploying Ai and all kinds
of different use cases so there's going
to be a lot of pushback against any
attempts to limit this technology right
like how do we manage that tension
between the between the the peaceful
wonderful uses and managing the risk
yeah we're kind of in 1939 with AI there
has been no Hiroshima there's been no
Nagasaki we haven't seen how devastating
this technology can be instead you have
a group of scientists who are
speculating based on being highly
informed about physics to understand I
can see
where this technology can go and we
ought to be doing something now to
prevent it from going everywhere and
having these really negative
consequences
but the rest of the world has not yet
acknowledged these harms and I think you
can see that there was a hearing in the
Senate you could see a lot of senators
were having a hard time wrapping their
heads around the implications of this
powerful technology that we're bringing
into the world so if we look at the
nuclear era and think about what we
might learn I think one lesson is that
developing and listening to highly
skilled technical people is key because
you've got to be monitoring and tracking
the right things or you're going to miss
out you're not gonna you're not going to
build an effective system second
you got to start somewhere and as we saw
with the the the birth of the iaea and
the npt when these things first started
they were weak they were incomplete
a credit or a skeptic would look at it
and say this doesn't do anything and in
fact even after the npt there were a
couple prominent failures you know just
a couple years later India tested what
it called a peaceful nuclear explosion
and a lot of people at that point said
the game is up this thing doesn't work
the npt is a failure
50 years later
we have only nine nuclear weapon States
and in fact the vast majority of
countries in the world the overwhelming
world's population has said we don't
need these weapons for our security they
have
stated that this is not part of their
national identity
it's not irrevocable it's possible they
could go back and decide at some point
to build nuclear weapons but it would
create so much friction and opposition
to do that and then of course there's
the issue of having a an insufficient
agreement in that it might create a
sense of full security exactly so how to
mitigate that I think it's challenging
something like AI we don't know
whether there will be
Advanced signs that things are going
wrong because these systems are
inherently hard to interpret at least
the current Cutting Edge systems that
people right we don't know what they
like black boxes they're relatively
opaque yeah so you could easily come to
a false sense of security
I think if you're really attentive you
can probably pick up on warning signs I
think as well in the biosecurity space
if you're attentive you can pick up on
warning signs and you can devise a
system that's going to provide that kind
of early warning but it's a really
challenging problem
[Music]